okay I have good news pretty good news I
guess I would say not the best news as
Trump would say but pretty pretty good
news it's like pretty good news we are
now within 85 patrons of securing the
support we are targeting to release this
12 to 15 part critical thinking
miniseries and the background as I've
explained before and earlier in the week
I gave you an update when we were 100
patrons away we are working on a 12 to
15 part miniseries all based on critical
thinking and it's tied to achieving 2100
patrons on our patreon donation page
which you can find at patreon.com slash
david pakman show once we reach 2,100
patrons this really great mini-series on
critical thinking and epistemology will
be released and if you go to
patreon.com/scishow you'll notice under
the goals section on the left side of
the page that there is a very clear 20
100 patron goal which when achieved will
trigger the release of this now on
Monday or Tuesday I told you that we
were 100 patrons away from 2100 we've
continued to chip away at the goal and
we are now within 85 patrons of the
2,100 patron goal we are continuing to
move ahead with pieces of this but it is
a big project I showed it to you earlier
the really great animated introduction
for the critical thinking miniseries is
effectively done our television and
online video audience is seeing this
again we talked about the list of topics
we'll talk about premises and arguments
logical fallacies valid versus sound
arguments implicit versus explicit
premises it's going to be really really
great and I've talked about you know we
talked often extemporaneously
I actually used the word
extemporaneously extemporaneously which
is an interesting interesting little
thing we've talked extemporaneously
about the sort of crisis of lack of
critical thinking skills in the United
States in schools students arriving at
college lacking what really should be
basic skills that start being
I would argue in middle school if not
first year of high school and so we're
not only advocating for that when it
comes to education reform we're also
doing something about it ourselves which
is we're putting together a mini-series
on some of these basic critical thinking
topics so I think this is gonna be
absolutely fantastic Pat yeah and we are
now only 85 patrons away and I encourage
people in the audience to help get us
closer we also speak extemporaneously
about many of the things that you'll
find within this critical thinking
miniseries yes Tom an argument red
herring or you know the difference
between something being ballad or sound
we talk about all that stuff no question
about it this really boils it down into
a whole miniseries and in fact during
interviews I will often use these
concepts to critique the assertions of
the person that I'm interviewing that
might happen later today for example in
my interview that's upcoming with see
Edmund right but this will be great so
help us get us help get us there
patreon.com slash david pakman show if
you can throw in a dollar please do it
because since it's a patron goal it
doesn't matter how much you can
contribute once we hit the 2,100 patrons
we are there and I'm very excited about
this I think this will have been in
retrospect after it happens one of the
best and best produced things it's not
really something that's right because we
produce a lot of really great things on
the program I'm on Reddit and I'm on
Twitter and on Twitter you can find me
at Dee Pakman or at David Pakman show
we'll take a break and be back right
after this